tout le faste aux républicains pour
accueillir un nouvel académicien une
réception solennelle en présence du
président français pour le célèbre
auteur québécois issia la parole est à
monsieur banny le cloneur ce moment là
dany laferrière en rêvait depuis des
années cintré dans son habit vert tout
neuf du mortel
il a fait l'éloge de celui qui l'a
précédé dans le fauteuil numéro 2 hector
bianciotti goût est cédée en 2012 ici on
se souvient des torts bianciotti comme
de normes généreux élégant et cultivé
sous la majestueuse coupole de
l'académie
l'auteur de l'énigme du retour a
longuement parlé de l'exil d'haïti et du
québec citant au passage le poète
québécois gaston miron mattera mère
mattera mende ma patrie d'haleine dans
la touffe des vents j'ai de droit la
difficile et poignante présence
un discours qui lui a valu une ovation
l'académie didon attendait depuis
longtemps un digne représentant de la
mairie
léthel d'amélie nous vous venez monsieur
nous les chéris sont depuis toujours
dans cette compagnie un honneur d'autant
plus touchant pour l'écrivain que
beaucoup de ses proches étaient présents
tout comme bien des dignitaires français
québécois et haïtiens c'est une émotion
collective et tous les ans sont là comme
dans un vaste roman où ils seraient tous
les personnages ça l'idée d'écrire c'est
de rassembler autour de soi tous les
gens qu'on aime québécoise et haïtiennes
comme lui
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la
francophonie se réjouit de ce qu'elle
considère comme un nouveau signe
d'ouverture à l'académie gardienne de la
langue française
elle se doit aussi d'accueillir d'autres
voix qui ont fait leur cette langue et
qui lient à nos richesses aussi de leur
rapport au filet couillard le québec à
quoi être fier d'avoir enfin une voix à
l'académie nous honorons un grand
québécois qui devient un grand être
humain de la langue française universel
aujourd'hui qui a réussi à traduire
profondément ses deux identités sont
l'identité haïtienne son identité
québécoise
dany laferrière dit à la blague que s'il
est le premier québécois entrée à
l'académie française
c'est fini le sol jusqu'à présent avoir
songé envoyé une lettre de candidature
un geste que d'autres devraient imiter
selon lui de façon à ce qu'il ne soit
pas le dernier
et si jean françois bélanger hâte au
canada
et